when they walk into the place and find
an actual place in New York City where
they can actually drink and smoke at the
same time it blows their mind New York
City Mayor Michael Bloomberg recently
enacted a ban on smoking in all outdoor
public spaces building on earlier laws
banning smoking in bars restaurants and
20 feet from any building the mayor has
extended the banned to the wide open
expanses of parks beaches and even
pedestrian plazas sitting a few feet
from a constant stream of exhaust fumes
punitive taxation has driven the average
price of a pack of cigarettes up to more
than $11 per pack but some smokers will
not be denied their right to enjoy their
vice of choice and in a city renowned
for its innovation in Drive they have
figured out ways to work around the
bands smokers with sticker shock have
taken to purchasing Lucy's or loose
cigarettes commonly sold for $1 each by
Street entrepreneurs willing to take a
four hundred dollar fine and a
misdemeanor arrest as a necessary
expense of doing business
one loosey vendor actually credited the
rising cost of cigarettes with a boom in
his business audrey silk a retired New
York City police officer and the founder
of New York City citizens lobbying
against smoker harassment has taken to
growing tobacco in her backyard in
Brooklyn being able to grow my own has
saved me thousands of dollars that I
haven't had to pay to social engineers
with using the power taxation to coerce
me into behaving in the way they dictate
I'm supposed to behave which is no
smoking although smoking in bars is fast
becoming a quaint memory one downtown
bar continues to thrive as a legal
smoking establishment thanks to an
obscure grandfather clause before the
law changed I have you know spending my
own right trying to get customers just
like any other bar or restaurant in New
York City but after the law changed I
seem to have had a one-up and advantage
a small monopoly on the smokers in New
York City that likes to go out and drink
and smoke and most of my customers are
locals
I'm coming here for a few months couple
times a week and it's it's been good so
far there's a lot of conversation about
the world and freedom and what this
country means in addition to drinking
Guinness and smoking whatever it is
that's going to give us cancer 30 years
mm so good mix of a liberal culture
yeah whereas in the city you're gonna
hear Thomas Jefferson quoted I get a big
hunk of French tourists but are in love
with me when they walk into the place
and find an actual place in New York
City where they can actually drink and
smoke at the same time with the comfort
of sitting in a chair and having
something to drink and maybe eat at the
same time it blows their mind not that I
require people to smoke if they're going
to work here but I do let the potential
future employee know well in hand that
this is a tobacco establishment and if
they're at all uncomfortable I would
like to have them make that decision if
they were still interested in working in
a tobacco establishment in the last 13
years here I've not had one instant of
any sort of employee complaining about
working here in his smoke environment
the success of circuit tabac presents an
alternative model for the city one the
compressor of both customer choice and
economic freedom by letting businesses
prioritize their policies according to
customer demand if everybody wants this
bin lifts the law let's see how the true
that is rather than losing tax revenues
to the black market and the green market
perhaps the mayor who made billions in
the free market might want to consider
allowing bars and restaurants the choice
to follow marketplace demand and letting
the consumer decide whether or not to
patronize an establishment based on its
smoking policy
you